previously on TV sins you know this
isn't just an exercise this is real life
deceiving movie reference reading read
see burn Singh more lies I checked and
it's pretty clear absolutely nothing
took place in Minnesota between the
years of 2003 and 2011 this is not the
movie ominous character is shot
ominously with only their ominous eyes
ominously lit even though there is an
ominous light source that would create
this ominous effect cliche sure you can
tell this guy's an idiot to give away as
his belly but why God's white earth
would you run to the front of the
vehicle where your captor and the light
is I would give all the sins back if
this was Bambi's mother and the rest of
the season was Bambi versus Billy Bob
but also have to sue FX because my
script with that exact same pink title
has been sitting in the Library of
Congress since 1995 so it would be a
win-win I said we bring jell-o salad but
he said meatloaf she should have because
only Satanists bring jell-o salad to a
party it's a true story don't bother
looking it up maybe wear nicer tie you
gave me this time well if you were a
better salesman I'd watch a nicer day
Kitty sucks all the ass but she would be
outstanding at TV since the cinemasins
team motto somehow makes its way into
this episode I just about hooked the
pants off a little girl look I wasn't
going to see in any of the local
phraseology because honestly it's part
of the trunk but then someone had to go
and say they would hug the pants off a
kid and now my sin and dog wants to hunt
this poster he'd write my name on my
fist and Sharpie for I'd punch him on so
everyone else would know who did it
if they could read backwards you mean I
casualty it's almost like they filmed
this in Canada or that's how they say it
around these parts we call those eye
injuries you hosers Fago what happened
in your nose being nosey literally we're
not friends I mean maybe we will be
someday I gotta say if that were me in
your position I would have killed them
the acting talent on display in this
show is just insane and we haven't even
gotten to Allison Tolman Colin Hanks Bob
Odenkirk Keith Carradine or Kate Walsh
jet and I don't know if I've ever given
a sin off to a casting director but
Rachael tenner I'm doing it today
because this is just masterful work
found this 93 New Yorker suite my family
had an 87 New Yorker in that car
freaking talk to us man it would say
things like please fasten your seat belt
and the dart is ajar to which I would
reply it sure looks like a door to me my
point is not only that I was sitting my
own car at age 12 but that I was riding
around and freaking get 30 years ago
obviously the sin is that my car doesn't
talk to me like it used to yeah yeah
it's the middle of nowhere I get it but
shouldn't they at least have somebody
stay back and watch the accident scene
and running patrol car while they go on
this journey
man Vern Thurman unfortunately you have
the silliest name this side of Katniss
Everdeen Sam Hess wants to know okay
I'll admit it I thought this was going
to be a pointless exercise and
diminishing returns but damn it why is
this working so well come on in Chazz is
working the hair massaging the meat put
the whole team down to lose Tuesday
you've spread it to Marriott yeah it's
real sweet king-size bed you love the
lake
you name it actually it's a Marriott and
Ballou so king-size bed is about as you
name it as you're gonna get it gone up
to a specialist last month think you
might have the autism that's interesting
because I think Chaz might be the
[ __ ] you know guys their work they
talk about how they look up to their
brothers sometimes I tell people you're
dead geez I know we're trying to set up
Bilbo Watson as a sad-sack here but it's
like this entire town went to the
Stephen King school of bullying things
pg-13 strip clubs I don't care how dumb
you are if you grew up in Minnesota you
know you don't start shoveling out in
the middle you start by the door and
work your way out unless of course it's
one of those snowstorms that brings with
it a director who wants a creepy walking
from behind shot granted I'm not exactly
a car guy but does urine and the gas
line affect the alignment why the hell
does bad Santa so obviously unplug the
phone line and cast it aside right
before using the phone this is one of
those things that seems so intentionally
obvious that I'm sure someone in the
comments is going to tell me that hotel
phones in 2006 Minnesota are actually
cell phones that just look like
landlines to fool us tourists seriously
how do you miss something like that were
you off playing a heated game of duck
duck great up nice in the head you
didn't hear that from me maybe not but
several people within earshot probably
did in a whorehouse I would be to the
idea that Fargo presents a universe
where someone cheats on Kate Walsh seems
like a sin I bet Lester loves these
magic gloves they are on his hands as he
takes off his coat to hang it up but
then magically off his hands as the
camera cuts to close-up in fact he loves
them so much that after he slams them in
his hat and walks over to his desk he
apparently takes them out and slams them
into his hat again also I'm not sure
when he moved his briefcase after
setting it on the floor by the door but
there it is sitting under his desk
nicely the show has a lot of departments
firing on all cylinders the continuity
department is not one of them obvious
Cohen references clever but obvious I
never say no false consent you
as you spent your whole life thinking
there are rules there aren't cinemasins
apologists I'm having a baby Verne a
line of dialogue for Jim Varney's
abandoned project Ernest Oren estia
somehow it makes its way into this
episode gotta be a muster
you're not even half a man Appling
shaming oh hi 23 please exactly when did
these two decide to be pen pals and
chummy enough to exchange numbers how
does he know he's in room 23 the Jim
Carrey tell him mmmmmm
wait what I'm racking my brain trying to
figure out how any blood spatter got in
the kitchen he's in the basement for the
entire murder and then completely just
robes including shoes and hides the
weapon behind the washer before he even
comes upstairs exactly when did any
blood transfer all the way upstairs
this is not how Malvo said his gun down
mere seconds ago did it crawl up the
wall from the corner okay fine let's
assume he could knock himself out this
way but not Marge Gunderson is standing
right by an open door barely 20 feet
above how did she not hear him slam into
the wall don't want to sound too jeff
goldblum here but will we ever actually
see Fargo in our Fargo show discount
young Tom Hanks the first thing Gus
should have noticed here is that this
plate is fake considering in 2006
Minnesota plates ran a three letters
followed by three numbers plate system
or you could go get in your car and
drive away why would I do that because
some Road you should go down dammit the
show is going to be great isn't it no
Holly and his peak TV greeting asked I
don't have time to watch another show
soon here is four there being too much
good TV that's right I'm going reverse
psychology on the television industries
ass there's no way they admitted him
after being at a crime scene that
gruesome without documenting his every
scratch the fact that he thinks they
don't already know this wound is here is
as likely as a Minnesotan forgetting to
put some tots in their hot dish don't
you know
what fresh hell is this
yes I married the wrong Nygaard no you
don't worry I know I know you always
have what happens if you have an
accident
in your job I work at the library what
is harpus okay I got a sliver in here
look at that think you're so sure about
it maybe she just kill him for me
criss-cross but I'm gonna ask you again
what the heck do you want I am to kill
you no you can't be no we get stuff I'll
be nice hump be bumpy